[Music]
he's definitely recovered from where he
was in 2012 he's popular he's got the
potential of being a leadership
contender in the future which is
something we could never have imagined
two years ago his fortunes you tied to
the economy when the economy was going
nowhere the same was true for him his
only shambolic budget a couple of years
ago seemed to as if it was gonna burn
his reputation forever but now the
economy is booming so is his political
fortunes I think this experience of
government has taught him what works and
what doesn't what works is genuinely
bold radical conservative reforms what
it doesn't is trying to split the
difference with the Labor Party which
he's been trying to do my opinion for
far too long I think we're seeing in an
emerging evolving George Osborne I'm not
quite sure we've settled yeah but George
doesn't always would have you believe
that he really believed what you did
except the time would come for this so
you know we're going to get the recovery
back and then we're going to do all
these tax cutting things so give me
conservatism milord but not yet I mean
that was generally his vibe and now his
timetable is accelerating he's coming up
with the extracts of his speech James
quotes lend themselves to a sort of
mission accomplished narrative you can
imagine him at the next election going
off to be foreign secretary and as James
has already suggested so I think well I
you know read the transcript I thought
to myself well here we have George
Osborne preparing for two jobs
the first is foreign secretary this time
next year and the second is David
Cameron's job in 2018 there might be
some advantage in getting onto their
team Osborne now but the things good to
his friend isn't deal yes and he's
dreadful to his enemies getting a grudge
from George Osborne is one of the worst
things that can happen to your political
career and really simmers only just been
promoted after her comments about the
LIBOR scandal which was two years ago
and that was very much against George's
wishes that she got into the Treasury it
was also a great theory going around
right now this
Sajid Javid she was born you know
a friend of him promoted to the cabinet
now we'll Sajid Javid stand against a
transport in 2018
now there's one theory that he will do
this but he'll do it only to split the
Boris vote I know one seniors one
supporter who is ecstatic teasing all
the Javid fans saying you couldn't have
to choose between Javon and Boris hahaha
how do you like that with Osbourne is
sailing to victory the other theory is
that Javid will basically run on a joint
ticket with Osbourne and the Javid is
hoovering up the Tories you can bring
myself to support Osbourne but between
the two of them they can get the sort of
support now we're talking about an
election that may or may not happen in
three years time but is amazing how many
B's MPs play mental chess isn't if his
sit and plan the next five years and
George Osborne is a greatest mental
chess player in Westminster if that game
is played it probably will be one that
he wins